Hallo Guten Tag, mein Name ist Dülger Oglu, ich bin auf dieser Sättung als Assistenz Arzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschrieb hören.
Bevor Sie Ihre Beschwörden...
Ich habe Ihre Namen leider nicht ganz verstanden, wie heißt es?
Mein Name ist Dülger Oglu.
Du, Dülger Oglu.
Ja.
Das Griechisch.
Das ist türkische Nachname.
Türkisch? Ach so.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre Beschwörden erstellen, möchte ich ganz schnell ein paar personischen Daten fragen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Gerne, was wollen Sie denn wissen Herr Dotter?
Ja, wie heißt es Sie?
Ja, das hätte ich in so ein Wieser verraten.
Mein Name ist...
Mein Name ist Michael.
Van Dorf.
Ja.
Okay, könnt ihr uns ein bisschen nachnamen?
Van Dorf, wie man es bespricht?
Walter Anton, Nordpol.
Okay, okay.
Ja, Herr Van Dorf.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 49 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 23. August 1973.
1973, okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ein Gewicht.
Ja.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit ein paar Kilo Züge genommen, ohne dass ich das wollte,
aber ich wiege normalerweise 62 Kilo.
Aber ich habe jetzt circa 68 Kilo.
68 Kilo, okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ungefähr 1 Meter 69.
69, okay.
Herr Van Dorf, was für Sie zu uns?
Herr Dotter, jetzt habe ich Ihren Namen vergessen, aber ich sage einfach Herr Dotter.
Ich habe seit einigen Wochen schon,
bekomme ich immer schlechte Luft.
Und das wird immer schlimmer.
Okay.
Was meine Sie einige Woche, einige Wochen?
2 Wochen, 3 Wochen?
Schon länger.
Also ich habe am Anfang war das sehr langsam,
immer wenn ich gearbeitet habe,
wenn ich etwas getan habe oder gelaufen bin,
dann wurde ich sehr schnell kurzatmig.
Aber ich habe mir nichts dabei gedacht.
Und jetzt ist es sogar so,
dass ich in Ruhe, wenn ich sitze, bekomme ich schlechte Luft.
Okay.
Sie haben einige Wochen schlechte Luft, ja?
Ja.
Ihr dürft noch belastungsabhängig oder Lageabhängig?
Ich habe ja gerade eben gesagt,
am Anfang war das durch Belastung.
Jetzt ist es sogar in Ruhe.
Okay.
Okay, haben Sie Husten?
Manchmal aber nicht so oft.
Okay.
Wenn ich mich hinlege,
dann muss ich einfach mal Husten, das stimmt.
Aber ansonsten nicht.
Okay.
Okay, haben Sie zurzeit Luftnot?
Ja, deswegen bin ich gekommen.
Okay.
Herr Bandorf, haben Sie Unverträglichkeit
und haben Sie Allergie?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Nein.
Okay.
Gibt es in der Vorgeschichte Krankheiten,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ich meine, z.B. Brüsterkrankheiten,
erhöhte Brütthochdruck, erhöhte Brüttwertwerke
oder Schüttelkursen über Funktionen oder unter Funktionen.
Bisher war eigentlich nichts bekannt.
Ich hatte auch keine Probleme.
Gut, ich hatte, war auch nicht so oft beim Arzt,
weil ich eigentlich keine Probleme hatte.
Aber jetzt ist es irgendwie schlimm.
Okay.
Okay, haben Sie eine Smaargegessin?
Heute meinen Sie?
Ja, heute Mittag.
Mittag.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Beibedarf Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Das ist das erste Besuch?
Ja, das ist.
Ist das erste Besuch?
Wie gesagt, ich gehe sehr selten zum Arzt.
Okay.
Herr Van Dof,
haben Sie außerordentliches Bemächter
außer Luftnot?
Ich habe halt wenig Kraft.
Das merke ich, dass ich sehr schnell merke.
Okay.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Also, was meinen Sie mit Brustschmerzen?
Richtig Schmerzen habe ich nicht.
Wenn ich laufe, dann wird es schon ein bisschen eng.
Die Luft ist aber mehr im vornen Grund,
dass ich schlecht Luft bekomme.
Ein richtig enge Gefühl habe ich jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Herr Van Dof, ich würde zuerst diese Gespräche unterbrochen.
Unterbrechen, um ihre Vitalparameter zu messen.
Okay.
Was ist das mit Vitalparameter?
Ja, ich meine Sauerstoff-Sättigung
und Sauerstoff-Sättigung,
Herzfreqüenz, Atemfreqüenz
und noch EKG schreiben.
Okay.
Dann können wir weitermachen.
Okay, gerne.
Und was muss ich sagen?
Sauerstoff-Sättigung, 92.
92, ja.
Herzfreqüenz, 134 pro Minute.
130.
EKG, unregelmäßig Vorhoff-Limann.
Unregelmäßig Vorhoff-Limann.
Blutdruck, 110 pro 60.
110 pro 60.
Ja.
Okay.
Ja, das ist Herzfreqüenz, 134.
134, ja.
Okay, Herr Wandorf.
Ich würde für die Sauerstoff-Berlöse aufsetzen.
Ja, ich würde es ein bisschen, ja.
Ja, Sauerstoff-Berlöse aufsetzen.
Wenn sie gut geht, können wir weitermachen, ja?
Ja, okay, vielen Dank.
Ist Ihnen das gut?
Ja, ich denke, es wird ein bisschen besser. Danke.
Okay, danke schön.
Herr Wandorf, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben das in der Werkszeitraum so genommen?
Also ich denke so in zwei Wochen.
Ja, ich merke, dass auch meine Beine etwas dick geworden sind.
Okay, beide Beine oder?
Ja, ja, also, das ist so richtig geschwollen.
Okay, geschwollen.
Okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie in dieser betroffenen Gebiet Taubheitsgefühl und Krippeln?
Nein.
Nein, das nicht, aber die Beine sind halt etwas schwer geworden, das merke ich.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Beinwachsen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, an sich nicht, nein, das klappt noch ganz gut.
Okay, okay.
Ja, fühlen Sie sich viel brich?
Viel, aber habe ich nicht gehabt, nein.
Okay, das ist gut.
Haben Sie Kalten Schweiß oder Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschweiß ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein, habe ich nicht.
Kalten Schweiß?
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay, das ist gut.
Benüschen Sie zwei oder drei Kiste, um zu schlafen?
Ja, also ich merke, wenn ich mich flach hinlege, normalerweise schlafe ich auf der rechten Seite.
Das kann ich jetzt seit einigen Tagen nicht mehr, ich muss fast schon sitzen, um zu schlafen,
weil wenn ich mich hinlege, dann bekomme ich ganz schlecht Luft.
Okay, okay.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, Herr van Dorf, Sie haben kein Vorerkrankungen.
Nein.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert?
Okay, nicht operiert.
Sie haben auch gesagt, Sie nehmen keine Gelegätik oder Bye Biders Medikamente ein.
Ja, Barbaris.
Okay.
Lieben, Ihre Alternative Herr van Dorf?
Nein, leider, die sind schon vor einigen Jahren verstorben.
Okay, Herzlichen Bye Leiden.
Okay.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vater und Mutter Probleme erweinen?
Voran sind sie gestorben?
Wir möchten wissen, woran sie verstorben sind.
Ja, natürlich, meine Mutter hatte leider ein Krebsleiden und ist danach verstorben.
Und mein Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Okay, sie verstorben.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Okay.
Ist sie gesund?
Sie ist nünger als ich, circa 42 Jahre alt.
Und sie ist gesund, ja, sie hat dazu bisher auch keine Erkrankungen.
Okay, das ist gut.
Sind Sie vererratet?
Nein, nein.
Ich bin eine Freundin, aber ich bin nicht vererratet.
Okay, Lieben Sie zusammen oder?
Ja, ja.
Habt ihr Kinder, Herr van Dorf?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Was ist denn Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite in der Gastronomie.
Wir haben ein Restaurant.
Und da arbeite ich.
Okay, Sie sind Leiter oder?
Ja, ich bin der Leiter des Restaurants.
Und ich muss halt schauen, dass der Laden läuft, dass das Personal da ist,
dass der Service immer dann klappt, wenn Gäste da sind.
Ich bin sozusagen für die Organisation zuständig.
Okay, ja.
Brauchen Sie Herr van Dorf?
Ja, brauchen.
Hab ich früher mal gemacht, aber seit circa 10 Jahren nicht mehr.
Okay, Sie hatten geraucht, ja?
Ja, früher mal, ja.
Okay, wie viele Jahre hatten Sie geraucht?
15 Jahre, würde ich sagen.
Ja, das war immer so ungefähr eine Schachtel pro Tag.
Okay, eine Schachtel.
Sie haben 15 Jahre geraucht, ja?
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, sehr selten.
Okay, was meine Sie sehr selten?
Am Wochenende oder am Feiertag?
Nein, wenn ein Feier ist oder Geburtstag,
dann vielleicht mal, wenn Gäste mal da sind, aber ansonsten
trinke ich keine Alkohol.
Okay, was trinken Sie?
Ja, eher sein Wein.
Wein.
Okay, nehmen Sie diese Frage bitte nicht persönlich Herr van Dorf.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Hatten Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay, treiben Sie Sport, Herr van Dorf?
Ja, normalerweise mache ich regelmäßig Sport,
ich fahre Fahrrad und ich jogge einmal die Woche, ich laufe.
Okay, jogging und laufen, okay.
Also jogging ist ja laufend, ja.
Okay, sind Sie gegen Corona geimpft?
Nein.
Okay.
Ich wollte keine Impfung.
Hatten Sie in der sechs Monaten Ausland Reisen unternommen?
Ich war im Sommer mal für drei Wochen im Urlaub.
In welchem Land?
Ich war in Indonesien.
Indonesien.
Aber das war alles gut, jetzt keine Besonderheiten.
Okay.
Ja, Herr van Dorf, von meiner Seite habe ich alle wichtige Frage gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas für uns zufällig oder fragen Sie an mich?
Nein, ich möchte gerne wissen, was es ist,
weil das wird immer schlimm, weil ich dachte,
das ist erst mal am Anfang eine leichte Erkältung oder so,
das wird jetzt nicht besser.
Okay.
Das ist für etwas zu sagen, ich würde vorschlagen,
dass wir folgendermaßen vorgehen.
Zuerst würde ich Sie gerne körperlich untersuchen.
Dann würde ich Brut abnehmen,
danach würde ich Bildgebinde-Untersuchung durchführen.
Okay.
Wenn die Ergebnisse bei uns vorliegt, können wir weiter sprechen.
Das hört sich gut an.
Machen Sie das alles heute gleich hier?
Ja, wir machen das gleich.
Das ist aber schön, das ist gut.
Dann freue ich mich, dass ich hier an der richtigen Adresse bin.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit, Herr Doktor.
Ich hoffe, dass es mit dir ist.
Danke.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Schmerzen auf der Brust wurde gefragt.
Sie haben gesagt, dass es eine Erkältung ist.
Ich dachte, dass es eine Erkältung ist.
Ich habe vor 3 Monaten eine Woche eine Art Grippe-Erkältung gehabt.
Wann haben Sie erkältet?
Erkältung?
Vor circa 3 Monaten.
Sie haben die erste Symptome von der Erkältung.
Nach der Erkältung ist es losgegangen.
Das hat ganz langsam angefangen.
Jetzt ist es viel schlimmer geworden.
Hatten Sie so etwas, aber nur Herzrasen?
Schon einmal.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, da habe ich nicht gemerkt, nein.
Fühlen Sie sich momentan Herzrasen?
Ganz leicht, ich merke, dass das Herz innerlich ein bisschen vibriert.
Ich fühle mich sehr schwach und sehr krachtlos.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall in Nester-Seit?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Wie eine Bildgebung?
Eine Bildgebung, Ultraschall.
Der Lunge zeigt, Pleurer, Egoisse, Beidseid.
Ein Herz-Echo zeigt ein Perikade-August.
Eine sehr stark eingeschränkte Pumpleistung.
Ein großes Herz.
Ein geschränktes Punktleistung.
Ein Punktleistung, die Ejection ist weniger.
40 Prozent, sehr stark, sehr geschwächt.
10 Prozent.
Nein, 40 Prozent.
Das ist eine Echo-Befunde.
Mehr verrat ich nicht, ich glaube, es war schon viel.
Wir können jetzt zum Arztgespräch darüber gehen, kein Problem da sind.
Können wir durchschnittlich eine Behandlung?
Bitte, Hamdi.
Können wir als Herzgespiele empfangen und danach?
Okay, ja.
Konntest du das nicht verstanden?
Können wir durchschnittlich eine Behandlung durchführen?
Einleiten, innen durchführen, genau.
Okay, ich versuche das vorstellen.
Okay.
Hallo Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Das ist unser neuer Kollege aus der Türkei.
Wie heißt das?
Wir haben schon einen Patienten, dann erzählen Sie mal.
Okay.
Unserer Patient heißt Herr Michael Wandorf.
Er ist 49 Jahre alt und 68 kg schwer.
Er ist 1,69 m groß.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns aufgrund seit einigen Wochen bestehende,
progrediente Dispneur vor.
Der Patient berichtete, dass die Beschwerden in der Zeit verschlechtert hätten.
Der Patient fügte hinzu, dass die Beschwerden,
die Beschwerden, die Beschwerden.
Der Patient fügte hinzu, dass die Beschwerden.
werden? Ja, der Dispner beim Hinlegen, verschlecht der Tättern, aber das ist nicht guter Satz,
erbaut, der Partien. Berichtet über eine zunehmende Dispner beim Liegen. Ja, okay, zunehmende
Dispner beim Liegen. Und er hat eine verstärkte Ruhedüspne. Ja, und in der Zeit, am Anfang der Beschwerden
führte sich der Patient Dispner beim Belastung, bei der Belastung, aber zurzeit hat er in Ruheszeit
diese Beschwerden. Er hatte anfänglich oder am Anfang klagte der Patient über eine Belastungsdüspne,
jetzt hat der Patient eine zunehmende Ruhedüspne. Ja, die vegetativ anahmenen ist unauffällig bis
auf Ortopne, bis auf Ortopne und die Gechevollen, beide Beine. Er hat untergenken bei der Zeit.
Oder prefere die mehr? Vor Erkrankungen seien. Das heißt, was ist mit der Angina Pektoris? Hat der Angina Pektoris? Ja, und das ist nur Dispner, Entschuldigung.
Also der Patient hat keine Angina Pektoris. Ja, und es ist nur etwas sagen,
es sei keine Vorerkrankungen, es sei keine Vorerkrankungen bekannt.
Keine Bekannte? Nein, keine Bekannte.
Als Patient nehmen keine Medikamente ein, als Voroperationen seien nicht bekannt.
Die Fragen nach Allergie und Unfälträglichkeit wurden verneint. Und der Vater des Patienten erlitt myocard infakt, daran ist verstorben.
Ist er verstorben? Ja. Daran ist er verstorben.
Die Mutter des Patienten erlitt carcinom? Nein, leidet.
Er starb an den Folgen eines Carcinom. Was war ein Carcinom?
Ich habe nicht gefragt, Entschuldigung, wenn ich untersucht habe.
Er hat eine Gesunde, die er lebt mit seinen Freunden.
Er ist kein Kinder, er ist Leiter auf Gastronomie.
Er ist in einem Restaurant.
Seit zehn Jahren habe er mit dem Rauchen aufgehört.
Sie haben bis vor zehn Jahren etwa 15 Paketjahre geraucht.
Er ist vor zehn Jahren und hat 20 Geräte pro Tag geraucht.
Er ist seit 15 Jahren ein gelegentlicher Alkohol.
Er ist in der Region nicht gegen Corona geimpft.
Er ist seit 15 Jahren ein Gelegentlicher.